mas como fazer isso certo porque se você
você vai levar top Down muitas vezes ele
é necessário tem tem top Down que é
escrotisse lá de cima tem top dar um
aqui é maluquice necessário sempre e os
três têm maneiras diferentes de você
descer e principalmente o que você
discorda que você foi lá em cima e falou
olha isso aqui lá em cima Falou vai
falando com Deus né
a pessoa disse não falou eu sei que você
tá falando isso entendi mas não queremos
ir para o outro lado e você discorda vem
mente o seu time de fora
ou falta decepção né
pode estar pode estar sendo mais escroto
aí mas não às vezes não pode mas o
julgamento via de regras de categoria A
maneira como você interpreta e cada uma
dessas três casinhas Vai mudar como você
vai dar o top dar um time depois isso e
acho que isso é difícil porque vamos
supor que você teria percepção tá de
novo você teve essa percepção de que
alguém
que dá um escroto em você e que não faz
sentido e você falou a pessoa falou não
mesmo assim vamos você como é que você
desce sobre o time de um jeito que não
vai desanimar o time e considerando que
o time já sabe tá alinhado contigo do
caminho oposto que foi mandado entendeu
isso é muito difícil Como fazer isso
vamos falar sobre terapia
cara
tem um ponto assim quando eu gosto de
pensar que quando eu era PM eu tinha
muito hate nas pessoas que faziam isso
o que tava um top Down E aí você vira a
pessoa que precisa dar o top Então acho
que eu já sou muito mais simpática
quando eu tô top Down do que eu era
antigamente Então o que eu tento fazer
hoje em dia cara a gente nunca é dono de
toda a verdade
né então a pessoa Às vezes tem um
contexto maior do que o seu então vai
parecer que é escroto para você mas ela
tem um contexto maior e diferente do que
o que você tem naquele momento
então muito do que eu combino o jogo
assim cara vamos compartilhar com texto
com texto é rei mesmo que eu tenha um
pouco eu vou dar esse pouco de contexto
sem dizer que foi algo escroto né mas o
que eu tento fazer muitas vezes é tá sei
lá vamos pintar essa lata aqui de roxo
beleza por que que a gente pintaria de
roxo aonde está por trás Qual que é a
lógica que lógica de pensamento poderia
estar aqui atrás e aí construir essa
lógica para conseguir descer para o time
E aí você vai ter que encontrar uma
lógica Porque para mim assim se você
acha que é errado desse tipo dizendo
assim olha pessoal eu não concordo muito
mas eles querem apostar nesse lado você
acha que você devia falar que você não
concorda e que você batalhou para não
conseguir ou não Você devia
ser que você tá comprada isso é relativa
você não precisa mostrar que você tá
comprada você pode mostrar o ponto de
vista que outra pessoa trouxe de uma
forma diferente então Ó o meu ponto de
vista era nessa linha mas trouxeram esse
ponto de vista e cara que que a gente
faz em produto a gente é testa coisa
então vamos olhar na Perspectiva desse
ponto de vista como a gente vai lida se
ele tá bom ou não
eu acho tem uma sutileza aí que é
delicada que é Eu por exemplo sou muito
transparente eu sempre falo tipo assim
mas eu acho que é você não pode meinar
confiança na liderança da empresa então
você não pode falar Tipo a putz
mas vão ter que fazer e é isso você tem
que falar tipo Poxa eu discutir com tal
pessoa Esse foi o contexto Esse foi o
racional eu sei que a gente vê aquela
outra discussão mas assim cara eu confio
muito na decisão dessa pessoa Acho que
essa pessoa conhece muito do contexto
daqui é bastante tempo então vamos
seguir a recomendação dela e eu não
consigo negociar essa decisão agora
então acho que o importante é a forma
que você passa não pode ter toxicidade
você não pode ter tipo recentemente com
o que aconteceu sabe você tem que trazer
de uma forma madura de uma forma tipo
cara normal tem hora que a gente vai
discordar mas a gente vai ter que seguir
o jogo
mas você não pode me dar a confiança
nessas lideranças maiores porque senão
você vai construindo essa Cultura de
tipo se eu falar não adianta para nada
né porque depois eu vou tomar top Down E
aí essa é a pior cultura que você
constrói numa empresa de produto né Na
real você perde o time né Você vai
pensar assim Ah legal enquanto a
Fernanda tiver aqui brigando por mim
legal mas e se ela sair Ah talvez seja
melhor sair antes dela então e aí daqui
a pouco as pessoas estão querendo ir
embora você vira uma bolha né E na
verdade assim é muito louco assim agora
falando sobre terapia
e Psicologia por trás
quando alguém te dá um toque Down isso
te gera uma insegurança
e às vezes a gente tende a reagir mal
porque cara alguém pensou numa coisa que
eu não pensei logo eu sou incompetente
isso bem no subconsciente se eu sou
incompetente vou perder o meu emprego
caramba ferrou Então o que a gente
precisa pensar é assim por trás da nossa
reação até para colher a nossa reação
existe uma insegurança que é natural
quando você toma um top Down Então como
você também volta meio que dando
Highlight nas coisas que você é bom para
falar não tá tudo bem eu sou boa nisso
aqui e Cara outra pessoa só teve uma
ideia diferente na minha e beleza né
porque essa parte da insegurança ela
gera vários gatilhos de reação você acha
que isso vem mesmo quando você sabe que
a ideia da outra pessoa é ruim é pior
que a sua assim
isso quer perguntar porque vocês estão
ainda assim
mas Tem situações que você fala assim
isso é uma bosta feio exato entendeu
um negócio que ela queria ter pensado
nisso pensei pô legal chegou lá né mas
então todas vai cair isso aqui é óbvio
que vai dar errado mas aí é evidente que
vai dar errado eu vou ter que dizer pro
meu time e o meu time não é trouxa é o
meu time sabe que vai dar errado meu
time sabe até que eu jamais faria um
negócio desse exato não sei se já passar
eu já passei mas não vou contar essa
história não daqui a pouco eu conto
daqui a pouco pode ser eu Socorro
não isso aí é mero essa essa caneca que
é maravilhosa goodset Fast Skill
Berenice
um jeito de testar e argumentar mas feio
mas desculpa pessoal só fazer um follow
rápido e se o seu teste deu errado lá em
cima a pessoa disse assim não mas não
testou direito
é normal isso é normal porque eu medroso
o teste não foi bom o teste não vai
dizer aí você faz e mostra o resultado E
ele provavelmente vai ser igual
Resumindo engole o choro é isso mas você
faz mostra o resultado ele vai ser igual
ao teste vai ser igual ao teste aí você
faz isso algumas vezes e você vai só que
depois você faz falou viu olha que coisa
foi igual o teste bacana né porque você
vai trazer consciência para pessoa de
que cara o teste tem valor e a gente
precisa testar antes então teve esse
engole o choro faz depois você volta
falou que coisa louca né deu exatamente
a mesma coisa incrível
eu acho que tem um ponto de escolher
suas brigas também nessa história que é
não foi tudo bem que tá mas dois top dá
uns bem intensos um deles eu falei cara
Eu discordo mas assim eu não vou ganhar
essa briga eu não tenho que fazer não
adianta bater o pé sabe então eu vou
descer da melhor forma para o time vou
engolir engolir o choro e segue o jogo e
tem uma outra forma que é bater o pé
Então teve uma vez também que eu bati o
pé e eu falei não vou fazer não vou
falar isso para o time E aí num ponto
tipo assim não mas você tem que fazer
também não vou falar e a pessoa fica me
olhando como se eu fosse louca
não fui demitida então sim você usou o
velho bom na volta a gente compra não
comprou Exato eu falei eu só não vou
fazer e foi isso sim e eu bati o pé e
assim prejudicou minha relação com a
pessoa que me deu Total prejudicou Mas
eu achei que essa briga valia mais do
que fazer a merda entendeu Então eu
corri o risco eu falei eu entendo minha
posição na empresa
eu sei o valor que eu entrego sabe Então
nesse caso eu posso bater o pé é um bom
ponto porque tem um outro ponto que a Fê
falou ah você mostra você faz o teste
depois você chega com a pessoa e mostra
que os testes mas isso isso a gente fala
parece é coisa de um mês isso demora um
ano e ao mesmo tempo você pode estar
querendo mal hábito essa pessoa aí eu
quero também falar disso Porque conforme
você vai criando escala você começa a
ter muito mais pedidos e muito mais top
dá
porque você tem mais com muita força
porque às vezes não é o top Down direto
é que eles têm que Rodrigo com muita
força que ele chegou pelo cara que pode
te dar top Down e fala top que eu quero
fazer isso
então a escala deixa uma complexidade
maior e Se você começar a dizer sim para
os testes o teste deu errado Ah não você
não testou direito Faz de novo planeta
de sempre que ele falar deu errado você
vai implementar como é que você não cria
esse mal hábito somente a gente fala
porque você começa a ter pedidos e top
darwins o tempo inteiro você vai o que
ela falou você vai ter que comprar
algumas brigas mas simplesmente tem
briga que vale a pena você comprar mas
que você tem argumento às vezes para
comprar tem briga que você pode
simplesmente falar vou fazer
e tá ali é igual tá ali no later no
backlog em algum momento vou botar aqui
para ir algum dia fazer que a gente pode
usar uma frase mais maravilhosa o
saquinho de ideia merda muito obrigada
é isso Adib lembranças saquinho de ideia
mesmo e
Então é isso assim tem hora cara você
vai ter que
ignorar vou fingir que não
tem uma clássica que fala assim
acho uma ideia gostei muito boa e se a
gente não fizesse
ótimo E se a gente não quiser
muitas vezes as pessoas estão assistindo
tanto que eu aguento eu falo tá bom você
quer fazer vamos fazer tá aqui é top 5
próximas coisas qual você tira no lugar
ela não tira nada não tem contexto 5 e
segundo que ela fala Putz melhor não
meteu o dedo aqui que se der ruim eu que
vou levar pode vir uma chance então
vamos contratar mais gente fazer seis
coisas
contratado a gente faz Beleza vai
demorar seis meses até lá você já ganhou
espaço para fazer realmente a coisa
E aí gostou desse corte se você quiser
assista Episódio completo basta clicar
no link aqui na descrição e se você
gostou e quer deixar a gente sabendo
disso deixa o like e assine nosso canal
para a gente continuar trazendo conteúdo
gratuito aqui no YouTube